we talk about being in the studio with
an artist what's the session like you
could use lessons are big fun I mean we
have a ball in here this is like it's
like Disneyland if you like music this
is where you want to be you know it's
music happening all the time there's
musicians in and out there's singers all
over the place but my normal sessions
are if I'm working with an artist
they're in here we're listening in the
music we're talking about with what we
want to do we're going over the lyric
sheet making some notes then they'll go
into the booth I'll stay in here we
communicate back and forth and we just
start recording and my engineer sits
here he's been with me for 10 years
Andrew hey super amazing talented
engineer and producer in his own right
but the two of us will just be in here
going at it and sometimes it'll take an
hour sometimes it'll take six hours I
mean we have a crazy range of the amount
of time that it takes sometimes it takes
seven or eight days to record a great
vocal sometimes people can nail it and
one or two takes and it's just a lot of
collaboration you know I suggest ideas
as a singer and they say no Harvey
that's a horrible idea but I say we'll
try it anyways you know just negotiating
a lot of psychiatry going on you know
sometimes I'm trying to make them
accomplish something emotionally that
they're not in the mood to do so I have
to do you know trickery whatever I need
to do to get them to to act and sing a
certain way but that's that's part of my
job and that's what I do with everybody
that I work with and you know my goal as
a producer is to make the artist that
I'm working with give their best
performance or have their best song but
ultimately have the best performance
that they've ever had and that's how I
try and approach all my productions
let's go back to 1994 the world was a
much different place then you know
social media the internet was only a few
computer science majors knew about the
internet talk about the hits the divide
the the ability to create a hit to have
something go viral before the word viral
really existed versus today when
everyone's trying to get everything go
viral with whether it's their cooking
video
video and how much harder it is today or
maybe it's not harder I feel I mean I'm
sure there's some quantitative study you
could do to figure it out but I feel
personally it's equally difficult now as
it was then everybody's trying to do the
same thing you're trying to get your
music heard or your you know your TV
show seeing or your movie watch and
there's different technology now but
it's the same thing it's asking people
to like what you've created and putting
it out in front of people and giving
them choices giving them their the
option I think there's more choices now
because of Technology and there's so
much more content that's accessible by
consumers but it's the same game it's
like try and create something amazing
try and create something special
something that hits a nerve with the
public or is so real and so relevant
that they want to have it and then
you'll have something viral as you said
or you have a hit
same same game I think so many people
try to game the system now with the
viral video whether it's showing a baby
do something or a cat but it seems like
there's no there's no real unless
there's an algorithm we don't know about
there's nothing we really can do can you
talk about projects you've been
surprised at where either way you don't
have to name the names but in terms of
like putting something out there and
thinking it's going to be a hit or the
other way around and then seeing the
public respond in a different way yeah
the weird thing is is I try not to focus
too much on that I like to focus more on
the creative process and do things that
I think are great and as I said the
things that I have fun doing and once
I'm finished with him I try and release
him you know maybe that's just me
protecting myself from failure but I
just say I did a great job I love what I
did I love this piece of you know art
that we created hope other people like
it too and we put it out in the world so
I don't really have a great experience a
great story to share with you of
something that was so disappointing or
something so surprising because you
don't know what's gonna work you don't
know what people are gonna take to
if you're a successful producer in the
music world at least you have to have
your tastes somewhat aligned with the
general public what I like
hopefully lines up with what the people
like because when I'm here making music
I'm not thinking like oh wow I wonder
what all these people are gonna listen
to or what they're gonna like on the
radio or when they stream this or how is
gonna sound with them I'm listening to
what I like and I'm making it to please
my personal tastes because that's the
only thing I know is what my tastes are
and as long as my tastes and my likes
and dislikes are somewhat aligned with
the general public then I'll continue to
be a working producer if my tastes Falls
totally out of line with what's going on
with the public and I lose touch then no
one's gonna hire me because I'm gonna be
making complete misfires and I'll be
making stuff that's not translating to
anyone else so that's kind of a simple
formula to explain how I think producers
that are successful are able to keep
working
you